[Applause]
we are back with fellow Travelers
co-star Matt Bower and Jonathan Bailey
and Rossy Ross Matthews is here are you
kidding me I had to come out there had
to be someone good-looking on the stage
it was about time and uh we are obsessed
with your show we are talking during the
break and now we're going to welcome
some of your castmates please welcome
Allison Williams gelani Aladdin and Noah
J Ricket come
on
[Applause]
W hi we have just been living in your
world in your show I mean it's about
love and Humanity Allison the last time
we were together I was yeah yeah remind
me what happened last actually I think I
have a visual
reference 15 million people watch
this um
yeah your dedication to character
was
at I have to say like truly among the
more surreal experiences of my entire
life and I've had a baby
um but it I saw that in my dreams for a
little
while I bet they were fever dreams it
was so it was so funny um now your
character you're in a relationship with
someone who has love elsewhere but you
also have this beautiful family and
you're married you're married with Matt
and because thises yeah because this
goes over 30 years you just see that
whole life you know um we go through a
lot together and it was really important
to us that especially in the'80s there
was evidence of that lived experience in
our in our love I always felt that it
was real love totally they love 100%
yeah different valid choices that were
made in the in the society that they
lived in yeah there were certainly
choices that had to be made there were
also drag
queens which was Noah I know you know I
know a thing or two about a drag queen
so when you were going out what was that
process like just transitioning into
drag what was this like oh my gosh it
was pretty it was pretty wild I mean the
first time I was in full drag was the
day of my screen test I remember walking
down the hallway to the set and I had
been in makeup and hair so long that I
totally forgot what I looked like and so
I'm walking and my heels are clacking on
the ground and then all of the sudden
everything stops and everyone looks at
me and I'm like oh God I'm fired I'm
getting fired I'm getting fired and then
I realize oh no they're they're
enthralled by my beautiful presence of
and I felt the the sensation of how
powerful it is to be a drag queen and
capture the attention of entire room so
it was an experience I'll never forget
and so I Love Frankie I love that even
in the 50s he paints his nails and pulls
his hair back and and unapologetically
is himself and also pulls out of Marcus
this like need to be yourself like there
is never a second where he's not
challenging being like why why are you
not um in love with who you are um and
and and kind of celebrating the fact
that you have this beautiful chocolate
black gay man um uh that was one of my
favorite lines for the show
[Music]